oh [ __ ] oh come on man you could get
that buffed out no you can get that buck
down
mm knock-and-talk
what the hell happened
Oh hands behind your head right now I
got this I'm gonna penetrate this man so
in my heart what watch sir I realized
that you scared
you know sometimes here deep you think
you got in his soul I'm done my son be
tired oh here we go again he wants your
legacy to be muscle shirts and body
counts look I didn't do all this you
didn't shoot anybody come on Kevin you
know I shot some yeah
[ __ ] me nice tres I never trusted
anybody I'm asking you man
bad boys one last time one last time I'm
the definition of the club
we try to do it we're not just black
with cops - we pull ourselves over later
right about the gun I've been telling
you ask for here he can [ __ ] Mike he's a
like a speed
bad boys bad what she done it what you
gonna do when we call it no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you [ __ ] up the lyrics which take a
long time to learn
[Music]